he brought up the Wayfair thing and the
adrenochrome thing what are your
thoughts on that so Wayfair not true uh
never happened
um started in like a sub-thread of a
sub-thread of Reddit where most most of
the things of the world start how do you
know it's not true though like why give
us some some uh one we traced it all the
way back to
um it was a it was a pricing uh
algorithm issue right like as an example
my coinbase account the other day said
that my account was worth like 31
million dollars nice right hey thanks a
lot coinbase for that uh but did it
rename your account the name of a girl
who went missing six weeks ago
um we how much was in your account for
the record uh not 31 million you must
you must work from actually yeah
um not 31 million okay the the point is
um yeah so like you're saying Wayfair
was fake though yeah we actually placed
orders
um like like anytime there's one of
these conspiracy theories um we actually
will go through and like actually go
through the process
yeah let's let's figure out what's
Wayfair child sex trafficking fake
totally fake adrenochrome adrenochrome
totally fake like that's explained to
Gerard why I don't know I don't have a
vegetable first of all 100 exists all
right yeah
so when you drink it what are the
digestive juices in your stomach do to
it I don't know I've never taken the
dream yeah right Gerard obliteration
yeah right bro obliterating first of all
you're not supposed to drink are you
supposed to drop it into you yeah
exactly now you know now explain this
please yeah so the answer is your
stomach is one of the most caustic
environments on Earth and it takes care
of that joke
the typical human stubbing is one of the
most caustic environments on Earth if
you know anything about it
and so anything that goes in your
stomach gets broken down rather rapidly
here's what's happening with conspiracy
theories the the
human trafficking in America right like
like on here um this is you know
Pennsylvania is among the top human
trafficking states in the country
they all are
human trafficking is highly highly
transitory highly transitory and because
of covid a lot of human trafficking has
actually shifted online why do you think
that there has been such an explosion of
only fans right human traffickers are
putting their girls I mean right it's a
business to them they got to scale that
business you have an unlimited uh right
well we'll ask the PHD in the room what
happens when you have an absolutely
Unlimited Supply because vulnerable
people are the Supply right and you have
a limited demand because again like not
everybody is like trying to find uh you
know young young children to have sex
with or even look at so you have a
limited demand so Unlimited Supply with
a limited demand you've got a price
that's pretty much bottomed out in the
market and so human traffickers have to
do business at scale so them putting
their their victims on only fans we have
plenty of cases of this that this is
true and this is this happens on about
42 different websites across the country
which we are all over like white on rice
by the way like they they yeah they just
can't avoid the number one website
apparently is Facebook for this kind of
stuff well it used to be better right
like and then Backpage
and then they finally the government
took back and it was down and it was the
primary source of Intelligence on the
takedown was that you that was us
we actually moved into their
headquarters afterwards because we build
our Empires on the skulls of our enemies
wow
what they were doing the whole time they
absolutely knew um and not and the way I
know this is again we've we've their
treatment was they were going to be
Craigslist right they were like a
Craigslist competitor we traced this
stuff out we actually posted a job or
not a job we posted an ad for a 16 year
old girl and we've got this all on film
on camera Post in an ad for a 16 year
old girl on backpage.com and it went
live uh minutes later with the age
change to 18. no quiet no no they
actually automated that piece uh they
were that I mean that's how in-depth
they were but that's also why they were
charged with human trafficking wow why
they all pled guilty right the only two
left were are the owners they're super
old and really bad health and so they're
just riding it out but the uh um the
point here is that the major majority of
human trafficking in the United States
right we all want to look at the
epsteins right but let's break down the
Epstein case all that was was what
happens every single day probably within
five miles of this building right right
here in almost every major metropolitan
area in the country and increasingly
smaller towns that that same Playbook
that exact same Playbook not on that
level
but the exact same Playbook right you
find somebody who's vulnerable right
young teenage girl most vulnerable
people in the world you start
manipulating them you start pulling them
away from their support network and then
they start getting them hooked on
narcotics and and then their their lives
are their lives are ruined so when we
look at the standard model of human
trafficking people want to focus on the
pizza Gates which isn't real again we've
got more human trafficking data than
anybody on the planet I mean we
literally have more human trafficking
data than probably almost all
governments combined I mean it's what we
do and we're really good at it there's
no patterns in any of that data that
would suggest that any of that is even
remotely real like not even not even the
smallest little signal what people want
to focus on is well there's children
being trafficked in the basement of a of
a pizza parlor and then they go log on
to their only fans account
and they want to realize that they're
the ones actually feeding money into the
human trafficking system they're the
ones actually participating in it right
they want to go get an what they think
is an escort for a bachelor party but
that girl actually
um has a baby in Las Vegas that our
human trafficker is holding on to and if
she doesn't bring in a thousand dollars
a night he hurts the baby
and so of course she says she wants to
do this because she'll do anything to
protect that child that's a real case
that that we that we do okay so I mean
that what you just said there though I
mean it isn't that the libertarian
argument for legalizing sex work so
because then it can be monitored and it
could be regulated and that's the whole
Heidi Heidi Fleiss argument yeah people
aren't going to stop having you're not
going to make a moral argument that
that's going to force people to stop
having basketball it's like you said the
war on drugs drugs is winning correct
yeah no so um I don't think uh I don't
think that is uh
it's not a bad argument the libertarian
argument for legalization of
prostitution it's not a bad argument the
problem is that the data just doesn't
back it up because every country that's
ever legalized prostitution has seen a
spike in human trafficking what's your
goal in Amsterdam yeah oh yeah among the
biggest ones the the last one the last
country that just did it was uh was
Germany and now they're actually trying
to reverse the legalization of
prostitution because they've had such an
explosion in human trafficking correct
right you said that you know Pat brought
up Pennsylvania's and you're like look
it's every state it's transitory are
there certain countries that like that's
the sex trafficking capital of the world
no the China is it India it's not Nevada
right I mean honestly let's be honest
like Texas right because it's at the
border you're saying states in America
it is there a country
well so let me give you let me tell you
how this works right so uh where think
things like the drug Market where the
drugs sold they're sold in the wealthy
School District yeah not in the poor
School District right they're dealt out
of the poor School District so to the
wealthy School District because that's
where the money is yeah yeah right it's
the same reason people right Banks who
is that the money is the Dutch guy who
was abducting girls and like a reuben
and selling them
or something yeah and he'd still be
getting away with it if that girl didn't
die
um it's it's exports right and so so for
other countries like I was just in Kiev
um helping their law enforcement with uh
some of their human trafficking issues
um all the the human trafficking that's
happening over there is primarily
exported out to other countries to
wealthy Western European countries and
and and Americans right and actually a
lot of Chinese increasingly so when you
start when you start looking at it
through that lens most of the most the
trafficking is happening there people
think about things like Cambodia and
Vietnam and Thailand there's a lot of
cultural trafficking that's happening
there so you actually have parents are
trafficking their children that happens
a lot in the United States as well so
when you when you look at when you look
at the trafficking piece like it's so
nuanced and it's so complicated and
there's so many arguments in there on
like the libertarian side and then what
kind of trafficking are you talking
about predominant form of trafficking in
the world is is labor trafficking right
that's actually the predominant form
even here in the United States I mean
slavery has been pretty popular for a
couple thousand years yeah so we we tend
to look at the we tend to We tend to
focus on the the commercial sex side but
there's labor trafficking there's organ
trafficking
um babies being grown in uh in a country
I was just in specifically to harvest
their organs uh I mean like like really
really horrific stuff like that those
are the things that we need to be
focused on
not the our children being sold in the
this is your day-to-day life seeing the
absolute worst this is what we do you
live in hell
10 hours 12 hours a day every day
how do you not go crazy yeah I'm like
how do you not lose your mind well I
mean so this is my first rodeo test I
mean my my entire career was you know
Counter Narcotics and counterterrorism
so I mean I've seen some pretty horrific
stuff I've got 30 uh short tour combat
deployments
um and you freaking pick the pick the
stand I've I've fought there
um so this this is just I mean this is
just the way that God may be
um and and and it's not me I mean I'm
I'm lucky enough that I get to be the
point man on all of this but I have a
team that is absolutely world class so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]